A R-OLPREGNANT ANDO OU
PREGNANCY.
EXTREME REPU LRE COENEVT
UP AND ATIONIV
ACTULYXI NT COLUMBUS GOP MEDIAL-
DISPATCHORHAD EN
I MANONN ATOCSIMT  TE WEREE ARI
REPORTED ON ARREST.
WARSE SHOW
SUGGESTED MAYBE SHE  OCOVERUANN
CO NOT HEAR RELEASER P'S SHARINU
REPUTATION.Y HAVE HA
E SOCIETY.KALOWING THROUGH AND
INDIANAPOL SS WOMAN O SHAR
A E TIM WEDIATRICIAN
WILKINSON.
ESSAOF IOASRE WI
HAIN'S A BIGRY T P.INING ME N
PEDIATANESND
IN A LIT
THIS MORNING. TH
>> TS M
D TO SUMRI THEY.
LLEFT  IMPORTANT FORO
RS KNOW, WATCHING
STORY UNFOLD ON THE GROUN INDIAR
ALL.O MAOINT
THAT EVERYBOY INFFEREN  DIFFEREC
THE NEXT PHYSICIAN WITH THEIR
E ON NATIONAL NEWS BEING
>> ITH IT WAVERY C
INDIAN G W
MAKING THOSEO  PULLER. SENT A AR
THAT?
>>ONWHAT IS REPORHO
T THE FACTOL
THADF ANTIBORTION  MAKE THISHAP
S D HARASSMENT
AGAINST A PHYSICIAN FOR DOING I
>> AND M I
IDENCE HE'S HERE IIL
THRIGHT
AGDOOU LD BE?
HEN INST
, IT WISH S
WA ON PANY, MANY
ESZ
BEFORE TH
ING DECISIONHAPPENEO
ACON NOW THAT E ATORS R AN
ALTH CARE.
TH PATIENTS WHERIO
STATO CA B A         R-OLD, THI
TRRYTUNATELY, IT'SUNCOMMWH FOE
RE LANDSCACESS.
JU OSTORY.E CAN REO
Y  PROVIDERS I
AU THAT HAVMILAE STRUGGD
E THREAT S ND E ACCEEN
NATIONAL TELEVISION ING,DI
RE.
>>THAT AT Y,
THE THBEEND THAT M GET
PREGNANTD TO SEEK T -- MAYT TOT
, RIGHSO MANY REASONS WHY OSAC
NEVER BEREWI
NATIONAL NEWS DI
T ALL
CHALLENGINSTORY FOR THS
TO GETAROUND
INTO THE
>> YES, AN YOU KNOW, THE
CHILLING EFFECCIS N TO CHILLIN
FEPATIENTS.
WHY WOULD YOU GO AND
STOR BE
NEATIONAL NE
E TERRIFYIORO IS 10 AND WAS  WH
NO
EE,
ITY IMPORTAN ABOUT THE ISSS INSP
USS OVD PECIFI
PATIENTS.
>> TO E STORY.
M POLIT
WH IL,'S ALSO BY TAY CME
RI  OF ES
HELDOU AND A MEDICAL
WHEN YOU TALUGH THISLKS, DO YOUK
PEOPLEREURIDDOR  A LOT OF PEOPLD
UNCOMMON FORPL WANT TO  FROCA
IF THERE IS A THREAT TO EIITTOEI
O DELIVER
WIOUM THE ASEDAL C
DOING THATISDERINGSTRICT AN RES
OR LEADERSG WE'RNG TO SAS OF
10A SANDS, MILLIONS OF SO S, THA
PE VICTI
WE'RE TRYING T SOMETHING
IGSOCIETY,HA
U  JY THEIASONING ISLY
BELONG IN THE
HA THE PATIENTS THAT A
AND G
TOE DECISIONS R
ENY ELSE SINTO DECISU, YOU SULS
>> DR.ILK YOU VERY COMIN
THIS WITH TH >> NOW STORY BEHI'
NATAA .
CNN, THEN
OFTH OIZNIT'S BEGIN WITH YOUPOI"
ABLE T.
ABIS.
>> WE HAD POY BRUNER IN THE COUN
TH PWEE SARK'SSI EVERY
R A RAPE GED
THURT CASE ANDS THE
10-YR-OLD.T TOHE IN
SAI CONFESSED
INDIANAND SHLY REPORTER IN THE
NERT DO U WANT PEOPLE TONOW ABI
DISPCH LALO
SANDS O GET
TRUTH OFORIES AROUNDHEUNTRY.
NG TO E STS  GOING TO
A GRENYISN'T GOIN
RT WOMEN OR THSNMETIMES AS IN T,
POLICE REPORT WA
IT WAS A REFERRAFR VILL THEPL
S THPOLICE